What makes good notification?
>> That's a great question.
So a lot of times when I teach people
about the hook model, they say, okay,
I get the trigger phase,
we need to prompt people to action, but
how do we make sure that
we don't spam people?
How do we know we're not sending them
too many of these triggers that they
become ineffective?
And there's a secret here.
The secret is that we have to
closely couple the external trigger,
the notification,
the message that tells the user what
to do with the internal trigger.
The internal trigger is this situation,
the emotion, the routine,
the place, whatever it is that prompts
the user to act on their own accord.
So the closer we can couple
these two things, right?
The closer we can couple
the notification with the sensation or
the urge of this is
what I need in my day.
That's magic.
That's the difference between magic and
SPAM, is context.
So that's the key.
If you can closely couple those two,
and that, of course,
starts with an examination, doing a bit
of a narrative on your user to figure
out when are they most likely to need
this product throughout their day.
So don't just willy-nilly send
them notifications all day long.
But couple those
notifications with a time and
place when your user is most likely
to actually need the solution.
>> So there's a delightful moment and
you couple it with authentication.
>> Right.
Well it's a moment when
the user has this need.
So for example, let's say I'm building
an app that plays music, right?
A music service or
a news service, right?
A great time to couple that need
is when I had the existing habit
of turning on my radio.
>> Right.
>> So if you could use geolocation or
other data or time of day data, or
appointment calendar information,
something that the user can tell you
about how they behave day to day, so
that you can appropriately target that
trigger at the moment in time
where it feels like magic.
Wow, I was just about
to turn on my radio,
I think I'll use this app instead.